Okay, what is with the term body count?
Does anybody else feel like it's just a little bit icky?
Anybody? Your meaning
to tell me that
we have normalized talking about people we have been intimate with
as nothing more than bodies?
I don't know, maybe it's just me,
but whenever I hear a person described as a body,
I instantly think of the process of death.
You know, after somebody dies,
you talk about, they're going to bury the body,
they're gonna cremate the body.
It's like a way of acknowledging that there is no soul,
there's no spirit inside of that body is just flesh and bones.
So to see that same language
used to describe somebody that you have been intimate with,
that you have done the most personal and,
dare I say, sacred thing that you could ever do with somebody,
it just seems so sad and dehumanizing.
I feel like it says a lot about what our culture thinks,
intimacy and sex,
and especially what hook up culture thinks of those things.
That a lot of times when you participate in hook up culture,
they really do view you as nothing more than flesh and bones.
A lot of people would say that a high body count is a big red flag,
and sure, maybe it is.
But I also think you should pay attention
to the way somebody talks about the people that they have slept with.
And if they're referring to them as Bodies.
I think that's also a red flag.